[Musique]
des statues qui représentent Jeanne
d'Arc il en existe quelques unes aux
États-Unis au Canada en Inde et environ
40000 oui 40 000 en France dont une
dizaine dans la seule ville d'Orléans où
l'héroïne national est représenté en
pied ou à cheval en robe ou en armure
cheveux courts ou longs triomphante ou
victime
aucun portrait d'elle n'a été fait de
son vivant ni aucune description précise
l'artiste est donc libre de l'imaginer
comme il veut aujourd'hui Jeanne d'Arc
ressemblerait peut-être à ça Christine
jeune femme russe qui est servie de
modèles au sculpteur Boris Lejeune quand
il a créé sa Jeanne
et elle m'a fait ce mouvement comme ça
que
j'appréciais donc de sentir parce qu'il
faut que le modèle sent le personnage
quelque part joue le personnage au début
je pensais faire Jeanne d'Arc au bûcher
Jeanne d'Arc souffrant christique après
jamais dit maintenant dans notre époque
peut-être c'est pas vraiment ça que les
gens attendent je suis allé dans
direction opposée carrément et je fais
j'ai commencé à réfléchir sur les jeunes
sur Jeanne très longtemps
la première phase ça c'est faut trouver
le mouvement le moment intérieur comme
ça il faut il faut que
les spectateurs chaque fois
quand il voit il voit quelque part un
mouvement éternel de personnage
Boris Lejeune descendant d'un soldat de
l'armée de Napoléon qui lui a légué un
patronyme français a quitté la Russie
dans les années 80
ici il s'est spécialisé dans la
représentation de figures historiques
religieuses et militaire comme le
général Biger un projet destiné à la
ville de Toul
il y a 10 ans on lui a proposé de
réaliser une première statue de Jeanne
d'Arc installée près du village natal de
la sainte dans les Vosges c'est à partir
de là que le directeur du centre
solgénithin de Moscou lui a fait une
autre proposition
[Musique]
de la statue de Jeanne d'Arc il a
beaucoup aimé est-ce que vous pouvez
faire pour notre musée au centre un
exemplaire comme ça
un peu plus tard une deuxième rencontre
avec une des figures de la mouvance
catholique traditionnaliste le prince
sixte Henri de Bourbon Parme a donné une
autre dimension au projet
il faut faire un grand jardin pour
Moscou
en signe de notre amitié
installez la première sainte catholique
dans les rues de Moscou en cadeau à
Vladimir Poutine c'était l'idée de
départ mais nous verrons demain que les
choses ne se sont pas tout à fait passer
comme prévu